so Sam 08
so he wants to play something for a
shake of Königsendich Grünfeld
I'm going to play C5 straight away
and some are always irritated by
actually a perfectly normal
Benooni but
well he really just plays slower than
me, although it's rare but sometimes it's probably
like that, that's not a UPS  normal Volga because
I have this chess
so here it's not a pawn C3 at all
I now have knight E4
the bishop D2 I just take away B5
yes I thought that too but
somehow I think it makes a strange
impression
because the T5 is so weak  So if he
now hangs E5 D5
and the combination of all these moves
looks somehow strange
so yes, he somehow ignored bishop G4
I could also play six back then,
that's an idea that's
annoying again that he can't get up here,
that's the best thing  He will probably have runner F1 on it,
but it will cost another few seconds
or even more
F1 then I'll just go back again,
yes,
it's a strange Volga structure,
so well, maybe he already has ideas
with F4, yes, really hard F4 E5,
I know too  not whether knight the
seven is really an idea to me now
because I don't think it looked good even without a combination, it
was good if he now plays A4 with the
idea then bishop B5 and so on,
but he plays well straight away but
I can only do it on e5  the five hit
so now I thought of Queen B4
with the idea then
and then taking the field to 5
so he prevented a
good E5 but it's not a
bad threat yet I'll
see what he does here now
gives me the A first  -Line
yes,
if he does E5 now
I can also hit the five,
that's how it
was here, penetrates,
puts it on E5 again, yes
it's really great, somehow it's
still not there, still doesn't have any
great things here
but
somehow you can't manage it
and B4 is perhaps a threat,
it could also be rubbish but I
really haven't seen a good move,
crazy somehow
either then the okay, I don't
think so, but you don't think that it's
coming through here
with the few pieces
that I have  I also do the four right away,
no, that was bad, I just have to
take five again,
so
now we're going to do all the stuff
here, do it quickly,
wow, that's not math or what ca
n't be,
well, do that first,
I'm so slow and he just has  48
no,
once snagged with the mouse and that
was it, shame
okay